jetzt ist es soweit meine damen und
herren der große moment wie immer zum
jahresende verleihen wir wieder unseren
begehrten goldenen vollpfosten und genau
dafür gebe ich jetzt direkt mal rüber
und die einzige noch geöffnete bar
deutschlands in die heute-show sebastian
pufpaff ja intensivpflege komischerweise
gibt es ja unter intensivpfleger kaum
querdenker warum eigentlich
selbstverständlich geht der erste posten
des tages das wird sie hier im system
nun im schlaf tv nicht überraschend an
die korona leute ja doll doch an wen
sonst inzwischen habe ich ja fast schon
respekt angesichts der aktuellen zahlen
immer noch eisern zu behaupten bill
gates und big pharma haben sich das
alles nur ausgedacht
also dafür muss man schon eine menge
brünen geraucht haben natürlich sollen
wir differenzieren das sind nicht alles
nur spinner also bis auf die spinne die
spinner die sind spinnen sie dennoch
eine elite gibt die kinder entlang
natürlich witzleben darauf was ist sogar
unicef ist der transporteur für die
ganzen unicef rollt die kinder und lenkt
sie den eliten was machen wir dann damit
messen lassen lassen kinder
gegeneinander kämpfen
der verlierer wird gefressen
die zu kindern schmeckt übrigens ein gut
geführter trockener riesling aber das
nur am rande
im grunde ist bei querdenken für jeden
was dabei esoterik meets reichs bürger
mit angebotes allwissend sie alle ein
die leicht aufgeblasenem überzeugung die
wahre wahrheit zu kennen weil sie noch
selber denken und sich nur aus seriösen
quellen informieren wie telegramm das
brehms tierleben unter den lexika aber
am traurigsten ist wirklich wie würdelos
sich die in not geratene afd gerade an
querdenker ran wenn er die notorischen
gute absaugung also den ist wirklich
kein argument zu blöd wenn wir nicht
testen würden dann würde die leute
einfach und geburt sterben
also ich stelle mir nicht am
krippenstein mehr an diesem corona virus
ist haben wir uns ja gut sie ja
irgendein weisheit ist doch scheißegal
wie das heißt sagt der fdp-mann stephan
broszio liebe zuschauer jeder von uns
hat inzwischen mindestens einen onkel in
der familie der auch so langsam weg
driftet richtung wahnsinn bitte und dass
man hier als bitte grenzen sie diese
menschen nicht aus im gegenteil
nehmen sie onkel manfred in einem
ruhigen moment einfach mal ganz fest in
den arm und wenn er sich dann langsam
entspannt wir haben sie ihnen die eben
spritze ryan babel der goldene fonds mit
globuli verziert geht stellvertretend
für alle corona leute an den grössten
intellektuellen der bewegung an attila
hildmann
und hier lieber attila kommt der singer
songwriter der heute-show friedemann
weise mit deinem licht erziele hildmann
wie schaffst du das immer so ruhig und
besonnen zu sein so heisst soviel ist
klar
ich liebe
hast du
fazit man nur lächeln so schön
kunst
ich hätte jetzt verwechselt in meinem
yogalehrer denn der ist auch veganer
egal trotzdem alles gute at love zum
pfosten kommen wir auch noch einmal raus
er geht an den fdp mann thomas kemmerich
der im februar für mehrere minuten
ministerpräsident von thüringen war
so nahm cejka schaffte unserer schalke
jene sich bestimmt an das historische
bild wo diese frau von der linkspartei
ihm herzlich gratuliert kemmerich
versucht dich mal den strauß zu fangen
du was für eine erbärmliche performance
ein fdp-politiker mit den stimmen der
ard zum landeschef gewählt und zum glück
nur in thüringen ein großes waldgebiet
mit einer handvoll einwohner wir von den
heute schwachen uns gefragt warum
braucht man da eigentlich
ministerpräsidenten dann müsste doch ein
förster reichen
[Gelächter]
es bleiben viele fragen ist kemmerich in
einer afd falle getappt oder war das
doch der versuch eine neue frische
koalition rechts von der mitte aus zu
probieren
das ist immer so bei den bei den
beobachtern danach stunden später ist
man viel schlauer und weiß was man tun
muss
herr kemmerich war offensichtlich
übermannt übermannt überwältigt
unschuldig ins ministerpräsidentenamt
gezwungen der an kemmerich oder danach
als er sich aus versehen auch noch
vereidigen lassen was für eine
pechsträhne ist thüringen überhaupt noch
aus der mitte regiert
fdp und linke haben zusammen mehr als 50
prozent
keine frage was in dem walter passiert
ist das war eine art diese hat man wir
erwarten einen dammbruch was die
reaktionen angeht das ist ein absoluter
dammbruch ein politischer dammbruch
dieser dammbruch dammbruch dammbruch
dammbruch dammbruch dammbruch dampf hoch
dann beim bruch
und für den dammbruch beides tut weh
gibt es jetzt diesen posten mit original
kemmerich glatze den ich nun den
ministerpräsidenten der herzen
symbolisch überreichte hier thomas frank
der landtagswahl in thüringen gab es ein
problem
es reichte nicht für damen und für den
anderen da wo 20
da gibt's auch immer ein der auf
demokratische gepflogenheiten scheiß mit
einem hinterzimmer trinke wann ein mann
die wahl mit stimme von den rechten
doch das klingt es ja nicht und es gab
ein happy end aber erstmal gratulierte
ihm der töpfe zu den po die
linken-chefin warfen blumen vor riesch
die fdp die seit jahren von nichts
gewusst und mercury anschluss und ein
falsches spiel
drei tage länger nicht und das war noch
drei zu viel aber sehen wir endlich auch
mal die guten nachrichten peter altmaier
sagt er will die geschäfte in unseren
innenstädten retten denn die sein zitat
teilen unserer deutschen einkaufskultur
trifft irgendwie mein humor wird also
die echte kulturelle langsam vor die
hunde geht
genau da hätten wir erstmal h&m weil
einkaufen kultur ist beethoven zb ist
jeden samstag zu pimkie gegangene nicht
missverstehen klar muss man versuchen
den einzelhandel zu retten 55 prozent
der deutschen innenstadthändler stehen
wohl kurz vor der pleite
und während eines city nach der anderen
verödet musste er wissen chef jeff bezos
jeden tag neue elefanten kaufen die in
seinem geldspeicher die scheinchen platt
treten großartig im dritten quartal 20
20 hat sich der amazon gewinn auf 5,4
milliarden euro verdreifacht landet
neben letzten ist der bams auch in
diesem jahr natürlich reichster mann der
welt vor allen masc auf platz drei ist
erneut der name besser zu lesen die
ex-frau von jeff bezos mackenzie bessers
bekannten vergangenen jahr nach der
scheidung ein aktienpaket es kostet
heute über 45 milliarden dollar
meine mutter hat mir damals noch gesagt
heiratete jeff bezos ich war so blöd
seit acht jahren kämpfen sie vergeblich
um einen tarifvertrag für die 16.000
arbeiter in den 15 deutschen
versandzentren jeff bezos weltherrschaft
ist praktisch nicht mehr aufzuhalten
deswegen wünschen sich ja viele kinder
dieses jahr weihnachten dass amazon
logistikzentrum von playmobil da tragen
alle figuren so kleine trecker und wenn
ich schnell gearbeitet oder aus global
der kriegt einen stromschlag ultra
realistische lieber chef das hier ist
dein goldener vollpfosten wir haben
ihnen wie man das von amazon kind beim
nachbarn abgegeben
herzlichen glückwunsch hier kommt dann
liegt der reichste mensch der welt ist
chef von amazon
wenn jemand was bestellt kriegt er einen
teil davon von dem geld nicht von der
bestellung es sowas wie jeder königin
keine steuer zahlen
[Musik]
reichste mensch der welt
du kannst dir denken so viel geld wird
auch nachteile haben zum beispiel eine
scheidung kostete 40 milliarden sogar
während der pandemie bereicherte er sich
du denkst dir sowas könnte ich nie
deshalb bist du auch nicht der beste weg
sein vorname ist jeff das englisch und
heißt chef sein nachname ist pesos das
heißt so viel wie jesus und deshalb
geben wir ihn gern so viel von unserem
geld und werden zu beschweren
beim reisen entstehen
so und jetzt ist der wichtigste goldene
vollpfosten von allen an der reihe a da
kommt er ja schon richtig der größe
vollpfosten den wir hier je verliehen
haben und der geht sie hanseaten
hochverdient an das ultimative kag jahr
2020 ein glück dass du bald vorbei ist
und hier kommt dein lied
[Musik]
duisburg
schlimmer
bei uns nicht
[Musik]
von heinz weg bis nach
das ganze jahr im hongbo
die schulen und die kitas dicht
doch statt durch den super
zurzeit haben ich glaub mich
[Musik]
abgepackte nur die
statt urlaub eine woche
alle
[Musik]
sein
das war
[Musik]
retteten die ärzte können
da bloß ein das kannte vor
doch gar nicht
ja
lauterbach
[Musik]
halbe jahr
und am wasser
was für
war
wenn das vorbei
ja
[Musik]
sein
es gab ja dieses jahr noch mehr
es war ja
spiel
er war 2006 egal
[Musik]
wir zählen
friedemann weise und das war die heute
show für dieses jahr wir sehen uns
wieder am 29 januar bis dahin machen
unsere online kollegen auf allen kanälen
weiter unter anderem mit einem frischen
youtube-video jede woche
[Musik]
was meinen arsch geigensolo war doch
versprochen
ihr könnt ihr in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]